you want to see the really cool part
it's inside come on let's go
what exactly makes the animated version
of the jungle book and its live action
counterparts so different and unique
some things have stayed the same like
the names of the characters and the core
story values
but these two films have enough
distinctions that you may not even call
the live-action version a remake at all
from varying creative visions from two
totally different directors
to the magic of cgi to a completely new
cast
we'll look at all the changes that were
made between these two films
don't you realize that you're a human
rudyard kipling's the jungle book was
brought to life by disney first in 1967
much to the delight of audiences
everywhere we all remember the colorful
and lighthearted animated film with
catchy songs like the bear necessities
so when the 2016 live action came out we
were shocked to see it have a much
darker tone
and different interpretations of the
characters among other things
first let's look at the creative
variations between wolfgang ryderman who
directed the animated 1967 version and
john favreau who directed the live
action one
the biggest difference is due to the
original source material itself
favreau and the screenwriter for the
2016 version of the jungle book
pulled heavily from rudyard kipling's
work which has pretty dark content
and let the original poetic words
influence the dialogue in action
this is a massive change from the
original because writherman and his team
weren't even allowed to read the book
let alone get inspiration from it
if that wasn't big enough of an
alteration check out the budget these
two films had
the original animated film worked with a
four million dollar budget
while favreau had 175 million dollars to
work with
that's one big step up from the original
of course
a budget discrepancy is to be expected
while the animation team worked long
hours to bring the 1967 version to life
the live action required a much bigger
budget to pull off the impressive cgi we
see in the movie
instead of drawing out the scenes as
they did in the animated feature
favreau utilized techniques like green
screen and computer animation to realize
his film
this leads to another huge contrast
between each film and that's what we see
on screen
i'll go back to the pack i'll go back to
aquila
one change you might have noticed
between the two films is mowgli himself
in the animated version mowgli can be
described as happy-go-lucky and silly
he's not any different from any other 10
year old boy you might meet
and he was raised by wolves throughout
the film he consistently finds something
to laugh about even when he gets into
trouble
he's a naive boy or man cub as they say
in the film
and truly doesn't know any better that
aspect isn't lost on the 2016 version of
mowgli
but neil seti's acting and john
favreau's vision brings a newfound
seriousness to the character that the
1967 version lacks
mowgli has a deep connection to the
jungle and serious respect for nature
also unlike his animated counterpart he
is very much
aware of the dangers that the jungle
holds while the animated version
presents the jungle as a paradise
the live-action version reminds us that
the jungle is a scary
although beautiful place there's also
selflessness to his character that the
1967 mowgli
doesn't have someone's gotta do
something
when share khan becomes a threat mowgli
bravely volunteers to leave the wolf
pack and save them from facing the angry
tiger
in the animation mowgli complains the
entire time and whines to be brought
back to his home
he lacks the emotional depth that the
2016 version has
one thing they do have in common is that
neither one of them wants to leave the
jungle
however leaving the jungle seems to be
what's safest for mowgli in both
versions
and that's thanks to share khan the
villainous tiger plays a much bigger
role in the live action which is quite
the change from the original
he'll get mowgli while he's young and
helpless
in the animation we only hear about
share khan we don't actually see him
until over halfway through the film
all we know about him is what we're told
by other characters
we learned from bakira that share khan
dislikes humans and their technology
but that's about as far as his
discontentment goes the 2016 share khan
is hungry for revenge bearing a scar
from mowgli's father
something the animated version lacks
from the beginning of the film to the
very end
he proves to be a vengeful beast that
will not stop until he's accomplished
his goal of getting rid of mowgli once
and for all
the live action brings the drama and the
darkness and that's in part due to share
khan's terrifying nature and actions
opposite of share khan is bakira the
panther in both versions
bakhira is a watchful eye over mowgli
there's wisdom to both characters
but the audience can tell early on that
the 2016 version
is much more invested in mowgli serving
as his mentor
i know he's special i raised him we see
it in the very beginning when bakira
lectures mowgli about being less like a
man and more like a wolf
in the 1967 version bagheera states that
he checks in on the mancub
every now and again and sometimes walks
with him the 2016 bagheera has a deep
emotional connection to mowgli and the
audience can feel
it and of course who can forget
characters like baloo
and kah phil harris's rendition of the
character in 1967
is iconic who doesn't love to sing along
to the bare necessities
he's carefree and relaxed but he comes
to care for mowgli immediately
bill murray's baloo on the other hand is
more so lazy and uses mowgli to get
honey
but where harris's baloo wanted to teach
mowgli to be a bear
murray's baloo helps mowgli to embrace
himself as he is
instead of forcing him to be something
he isn't that's a message anyone can
take to heart
i say you could be a man right here
kha's role in the film undergoes a
change as well between the two films
we watch him try and fail to eat mowgli
twice in the animated feature
he's hypnotic with his colorful eyes and
slick voice but he's got
nothing on the 2016 version scarlett
johansson entrances mowgli
and the audience with her smooth melodic
voice but
she also has some information on
mowgli's backstory something we don't
get in the animated feature
even though kha is only seen once in the
2016 version
she leaves a lasting impact it's
terrifying to watch
kaw the snake almost consume mowgli but
in both versions he is saved by a
helpful hand
just a minute i've never seen one before
with all these changes in character it's
no wonder that the ending had to change
along with them
the 1967 version showed share khan face
mowgli after he had resolved to be alone
in the jungle
blue then comes into the fray to help
him then when lightning strikes and sets
fire to a nearby tree
mowgli turns to man's greatest weapon to
defeat sher khan
in the 2016 version it seems that mowgli
2 will use fire or the red flower
to best his opponent but we watch in awe
as he ultimately rejects it
instead he relies on his man cub
ingenuity to save him at the very end
then once the danger presented by share
khan vanishes the two mowgli's take
different paths in the 1967 version
following a young girl with a beautiful
singing voice
mowgli returns to human society however
in the 2016 version
after embracing his human nature mowgli
makes a choice to stay in the jungle
with his animal family with all of these
distinctions to consider
we have to ask which film is better we
took a look at the scores on rotten
tomatoes to try to answer the question
the 1967 version of the jungle book
received an 88
from critics time magazine remarked the
result is thoroughly delightful
the reasons for its success lie in
disney's own unfettered animal spirits
his ability to be childlike without
being childish
on the other hand the 2016 version
garnered a 94 percent
james bartonelli a top critic from
realviews had this to say about the
movie
the jungle book is well made and
deserves recognition as one of the
year's best family offerings
thus far it seems that live action was
better received and it's no surprise why
favreau's vision brought a new
perspective to the film and it's a
refreshing and modern look at the
classic
the 2016 version is clearly not a shot
for shot remake
much to its benefit there are many
differences to be had between these two
incredible renditions of the jungle book
but it seems that the one with more
emotional depth and character
development
wins the day both versions of the jungle
book have their pros and cons
and they're both enjoyable movies to
watch you can't go wrong with either one
you want to know something we're good
sparring partners you'd better believe
it
now that we've covered the varying
characteristics between each film
which one do you prefer the animation or
the live action
what changes stood out to you the most
let us know down in the comments
thanks for watching